okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today
i'm going to talk about something that
i'm very passionate about
and that is women's sports so little
backstory
i
played college volleyball i played
college basketball i ran track and
college
on top of that i went and i played
volleyball in london and i also played
basketball here so when it comes to
women's sports i have been doing this my
entire life
this is the one thing that i've always
cared about
is sports okay
and
right now i'm finding out
that they are letting
men trans
trans women so biological men
that have undergone hormone replacement
for a year
to compete in women's sports
and
i keep hearing these liberals okay and
they keep saying
the research is inconclusive
so let's err on the side of inclusion
guys i don't know how [ __ ] stupid you
people can be i don't even really like
to swear but how how
how am i having a conversation with
grown adults
about are our men at an advantage
being in women's sports like okay let me
give you an example my brother
my older brother austin
he hasn't lifted in five years not
consistently he's never really worked
out never been his thing i am a semi-pro
athlete i played in college i played
multiple sports do you know who can
outbench me
him do you know who would still out
bench me even if he took freaking
hormones for a year
him
okay
and it's really convenient that the none
of the people that want to err on the
side of inclusion
play
if you talk to athletes about this
none of them are for this
none of them agree with this
and guys if if it's equal if it's really
equal between men and women
why
aren't women dominating in men's sports
why
why are only women the one
the ones with records that are being
broken
because
there's no difference right
and i don't need to listen to like i
don't need to read a study to tell me
this like
why
this is common sense
oh my god this is common sense and this
is going to be the end of women's sports
this is going to be the end of women's
sports because you are taking away
opportunity
like like the same feminists that
advocate for women's rights and advocate
for opportunities for women's women are
the same ones advocating to let
biological men take away opportunity
from us
we work so hard we are we are some of
the hardest working some of the hardest
working women that i know are athletes
because we work our whole lives
for very little pay little to no
opportunity
i'm probably in the top one percent
talent wise of like
skill from when
people started
there's not
there's not a lot of opportunity out
there and
like i don't understand biden is a grown
ass man
how do you not think there's a
difference
between biological men and biological
women and how do you not think that
there is an advantage
to men guys
i know i played basketball in college
okay i know if i play with a guy that
had maybe two years of high school he'll
probably beat me because i can't keep up
i'm not as strong and the crazy thing is
for me that would take away all
opportunity because i'm a center i'm in
the top one percent of height for
females and i'm not tall for a center
i'm about five eleven and a half six
foot
that is short in basketball now you want
me to compete with trans men where
fifteen percent of men are over six foot
so that would that would take me out
of any opportunity there would be and
it's the same thing with volleyball
and on top of that
you guys want us to share locker rooms
with biological men
and the people that say we should be
comfortable with it are not the ones
that have to do it
and i know that there are some trans
people a lot of trans people probably
the majority of trans people that aren't
going to do anything weird or
with
the locker rooms but guys when it comes
to policies there's always someone
that's going to abuse it and how
convenient is it that the people that
want us to take that risk aren't the
ones
that have to deal with the consequences
and that's how it always is all of you
idiots that are commenting on this none
of you are the ones that have to play
against these men
you want us to risk getting injured
injured you want you want i have worked
my whole life to build the body that i
have and get the skills that i have and
you want me to risk getting injured
because you're not sure the evidence is
not conclusive
not conclusive are you stupid
i don't even need to read a study to
know that there's a difference between a
biological man and a biological woman
and that they have an advantage
this is ridiculous ridic oh my god i'm
getting so mad this is ridiculous you
are taking away rights from women you
are taking away opportunities from women
the same party that says they advocate
so strongly for women's rights my body
my choice but it's not my choice if i
want
to share a locker room with them i can't
have women's only spaces
it's not my choice if they get to
compete in a league that's for women
you guys are idiots you are idiots if
you
believe in this stuff and if you're not
an athlete
if you're not an athlete and you don't
you're not currently competing
i don't want to hear from you your
opinion doesn't matter and if you
seriously
think that this is a good idea
let me know why in the comments because
you're probably stupid and you probably
have an iq of two i'm just saying
subscribe thanks